E aí
[Aplausos]
[Música]
em um dos dias mais felizes da minha
vida foi quando eu larguei a faculdade
de administração na USP eu já estava lá
há um ano e alguns meses e a cada dia
fazia menos sentido para mim eu sentia
que estava desperdiçando meu tempo que a
maioria dos conteúdos eu podia prender
lá em um livro sem sair de casa e a cada
dia eu me perguntava que que eu tô
fazendo com a minha vida
e quando eu falei para o meu pai para
minha mãe e para alguns amigos que eu ia
largar o curso para desenvolver um
malabarismo e criar conteúdo de
malabarismo e circo principalmente em
vídeo pela internet algumas pessoas me
chamaram de louco mas para mim não era
loucura era só sensatez
o anos depois eu descobri o trabalho do
Doc Savage que desenha as abas teens que
são as galinhas sensacionais e tenho uma
tirinha específica em que ele disse
Muitas pessoas te dizem como é difícil
ser artista você vai morrer de fome mas
quase ninguém te diz como é difícil não
ser artista eu acho muito interessante o
fato de que não dá para viver sem arte
não importa onde não importa quem e
nesse tempo de pandemia de quarentena
fica muito claro que o que salva as
pessoas não são as coisas caras que só
vão as pessoas podem comprar as joias os
roupas é cantar na varanda junto com os
vizinhos é fazer música e dançar como se
ninguém estivesse olhando é aprender
alguma coisa nova assistir um vídeo um
filme uma série pela internet é passar a
tarde inteira fazendo uma lá
os seus filhos ali com 3 bolinhas
e para as pessoas têm a sorte de ter um
teto para morar deter as condições
básicas de vida comida na geladeira
depois que caem os véus fica claro que a
busca infinita por dinheiro não deveria
ser a prioridade máxima a importância da
arte emerge e a gente começa a valorizar
mais as atividades autotélicas que tem
um fim em si mesmo
e eu sempre fui muito apaixonado por
aprender bastante auto de data isso que
é um jeito legal jennerjahn e aos 15
anos eu aprendi a jogar de rolou e
depois isso me levou naturalmente pelo
malabarismo com bolas e para uma
laborista de contato
e eu aprendi tudo pela internet e de
certa forma o trabalho que eu faço hoje
em dia é uma forma de devolver para
internet o que ela me trouxe e quando
você malabarista tem algumas coisas que
você ouve com bastante frequência
a nossa já dá para assinarem pô já
pensou em trabalhar em circo mas foi só
recentemente que eu vi essa daqui pela
primeira vez para quê
e para que aprender malabarismo E aí eu
achei essa pergunta muito curiosa eu fui
respondendo Pô eu podia te dizer que
vale a pena aprender malabares porque é
uma atividade que vai se conectar com a
comunidade Global porque todo mundo a
barista tem um amigo ou uma amiga em
praticamente qualquer lugar do mundo
porque é uma atividade que envolve o
corpo EA mente integra e equilibra esses
dois pontos porque aprendeu a lavar as
melhores reflexos fica progressivamente
mais desafiador porque é uma atividade
que você pode praticar sem sair de casa
qualquer pessoa pode aprender e você não
precisa nem de material profissional
para aprender dá para começar com as
frutas
Tá mas vem cá me diz uma coisa não tem
nada que você faz só por prazer mesmo só
porque é legal Depois que eu descobri
essa palavra autotélico eu não tenho uma
melhor para descrever o porquê de fazer
uma lavagem é autotélico tem um fim em
si mesmo
e eu acho interessante também que pensar
nos caminhos que eu poderia ter telhado
se eu não tivesse largado a faculdade
talvez eu tivesse hoje trabalhando numa
grande empresa ou no banco ajudando aí
de que ser mais um milionário mas eu
acho que isso teria sido um grande
desperdício porque aí eu não teria tido
contato com histórias como a do Igor
Vicentini por exemplo que aos 11 anos
começou a aprender malabarismo pelos
vídeos no YouTube e hoje ele joga 9 anos
9 ou a Claudia uma amiga da minha mãe
que uma vez me pediu para ensinar três
bolas para ela aí eu peguei falei
bolinhas vem na mão dela e fala aí
beleza da palavra me mostra o que que
você faria como você tentar ia começar a
jogar essas três bolas ela pegou
o que começou a jogar aí eu falei não
pera aí né Cláudia você falou que queria
que eu te ensinasse Mas você já sabe
jogar Como assim você já tentou anos não
não é não é a primeira vez que você tá
tentando e ela chegou para mim e falou
não mas eu sempre soube que eu ia
conseguir
é aquilo ficou oito anos na minha cabeça
eu sempre soube que eu ia conseguir
e ela tinha tanta certeza que todos os
obstáculos se afastaram
o e várias outras histórias também de
pessoas que me contam diariamente que
uma laborista trouxe um impacto positivo
para a vida delas ou até que elas saíram
situações muito difíceis situações de
depressão por causa de uma labareda
muito circo por terem descoberto e terem
mais contato com essa arte eu descobri
que quando eu faço o teu realmente
acredito eu contribuo para que outras
pessoas também façam que elas realmente
acreditam
I e II
e eu espero que um dia a gente veja os
malabaristas no sinal
Oi e a gente perceba que a ti é trabalho
duro é suor e que todo artista tem que
estar sempre em contato com tem dentro
dele não que tem dentro de cada artista
com os nossos medos os nossos desejos os
nossos erros e os nossos sonhos e aí
talvez a partir desse dia a gente ajude
a criar ainda mais espaços para dividir
trabalhos artísticos que escolas centros
culturais teatros lonas de circo
Inclusive tem uma tradição muito
interessante em algumas apresentações
circenses Principalmente quando a gente
apresenta para outros circense em que
quando você entra em cena e tenta fazer
um truque bem difícil às vezes Você erra
Oi e aí vocês estão a nova praia sabem
que aquele grupo era difícil e todo
mundo que tava lá assistindo dá suporte
para a pessoa que está em cena e grita
eu acredito então eu convido vocês
acreditarem junto comigo eu deixo aqui a
minha contribuição
e eu acredito
G1
e para fechar eu acho que vale a pena
dividir com vocês algumas palavras de
Rudolf Steiner que eu repito todos os
dias quando eu acordo e antes de dormir
e com firmeza é Ocupa um lugar no mundo
com certeza é o caminho pela vida com
esperança em tudo o que eu faço com Amor
No íntimo do meu ser com confiança no
meu pensar Força Jovem do meu coração
bom obrigado
o que diz o YouTube não é só queria
agradecer profundamente uma frase que
você existe eu queria te agradecer
a planta gente disse para a gente quanto
é difícil ser artista difícil de
escritório num país como o Brasil e eu
lutando cada vez tá largar um pouquinho
mais advocacia conseguiu pagar os
boletos com Livros mas ninguém nunca
tinha me dito o qual Difícil é não certo
difícil é silenciar as palavras que são
a razão da minha existência muito
obrigada a
e para que a gente encontra Raquel a paz
que farol que sair do meu coração e
apontava por esse caminho
Oi e aí foi por outros assim
é muito obrigado agradeço a gente ensaia
muitas vezes muitas coisas mas eu juro
ou para vocês que se a parte não tava
ensaiada e tá quando você um pouquinho
essa coisa da arte muito [ __ ] né porque
a gente não dá para encarar a realidade
sem ela ele e as coisas que você falou
assim disso foque muita coisa que que
não era invisível né o rio que fala Tem
coisas que a gente pimenta que são
indivisíveis e de repente acabo de
conhecer um cara que conseguiu dizer
tanta coisa né Então puxa Que presente
que você foi nessa história obrigada
muito obrigada pela sua vida e pelo
farol que acende aí nesse peito aqui
ilumina todo mundo nessa telinha verde
aí quem consegui receber isso é é só
para dizer que eu também acredito
eu também acredito que bom né
bom obrigada Ana mundo não é muito bom
linda e
E aí